you know I'm talking to Adam Hirsch
right now and bam I get motivated again
I know I put a video up today but I'm
putting up another one so if you're
watching this please scroll down and
watch the other one I put up today which
was my big thank you and we were talking
and you know you know he's at Mashable
and I was thinking god we need this
message of goodness and doing the right
thing and helping others I mean I've
been sitting here all day just answering
emails and helping people I'm getting
killed I'm trying to figure out how to
tape Wine Library TV I've got two
wristbands on I'm struggling out here
because I'm leaving for san fran
tomorrow and i'm speaking at google so
if anybody wanted to hit up google and
hang out and talk about wine and social
branding i'll be there but I was talking
to Adam and I'm like you know what more
people i was gonna say to him you know
you don't have to link to me but you
need to talk about this movement of good
people i mean the chris brogan Zanda
tara hunslet pistachios and the gym
coracles in the same houses and there's
just so many more I just lucked out
everybody I'm so sorry it aunty this and
there's just so many killer people so
many killer people and the things that I
see everybody writing about are you know
funding this or how to monetize that or
or this controversy or these people
broke up or how are they going to sell
or what money are they making or who's
getting ads and I'm just like my god if
this entire community there's so many
powerful voices and there's so many
great people like some of the people
that are that hated on but maybe
misunderstood the calc anuses and the
Michael Arrington's of the world where
so there's some more haters uh they're
good peeps i mean if people got to know
each other um it would be killer and i
would I guess what I'm asking for is a
call to action right now I want people
to spend all day tomorrow for 308
talking about good people Twitter them
up pounce them out blog about them
tomorrow four three two thousand eight
is talk about good people day can we
make this happen if we can make a color
war can we talk about good people